on a du mal à le croire mais il a fêté
cette année ses 80 ans et il garde
toujours cette énergie communicative et
cet amour intact de la chanson française
et de la scène il se confie également
aujourd'hui dans un joli livre dans
lequel il évoque ses succès ses 60 ans
de chansons mais aussi sa longue
traversée du désert
voici maintenant l'invité des cinq
dernières minutes qui s'est invitée
c'est marcel amont merci beaucoup au
jour soufi comment allez-vous sophie du
matin oui sur fi du matin qui a décalé
vers le midi est-ce que vous veniez me
voir et que vous faites marcel amont
pour avoir 80 ans et afficher une telle
forme dit je suis complètement refait de
la tête et ça c'est très bien fait c'est
quoi votre secret pas d'excès tout en
profitant sainement delà de l'avis de
tous les de toutes les opportunités de
tous les bonheurs qu'offre la vie est
d'essayer de pas trop sombre et quand ça
va mal alors pourquoi avoir attendu si
longtemps avant de vous confier un an ce
joli livre de souvenirs je n'avais pas
très envie de raconter ma vie et c'est
devenu si vous voulez j'ai accepté de le
faire parce que j'aime beaucoup
christian pirot l'éditeur qui a fini par
me convaincre
il adore la chanson et c'était en même
temps un levier pour cette rentrée dont
je rêvais dans un petit théâtre qui
s'appelle la grande comédie même si
c'est un peu vie serait à partir à la
fin de la semaine à partir de jeudi
voilà et c'était un levier parce que bon
qu'est ce qui se passe de scabreux ou
d'étonnant dans ma vie qui puisse
attirer les foules c'est à fait plein de
choses hein envie la foule à l'oeil
protubérants des brassens bon alors je
pensais qu'un livre de souvenirs mais
faut pas aller chercher des choses
croustillantes là-dedans jour par
beaucoup de la chanson en général et de
mon expérience est très petit en fait un
tout petit vous avez toujours voulu être
artiste savais pas que c'était un métier
d'ailleurs mon père disait tu crois
qu'avec son accent béarnais et tu crois
qu'on va te payer pour le faire le corps
de l'étudiante a créé un bail il y
croyait qu'en dise on commence à y
croire c'était pas de gaieté de coeur
non en 1950 alors vous quittez bordeaux
vous partez à paris pour tenter votre
chance ça pas été très facile début 1
c'est le lot de tous les provinciaux
poste quand on est dans notre bordeaux
où notre bruxelles pour brel ou ou simon
en bretagne et au moins chez papa et
maman en ahl gîte et le couvert là il
faut payer le resto il faut payer
l'hôtel est bon et puis c'est pas facile
mais pour les provinciaux c'est plus de
vie je pense à robert hossein ou
aznavour qui ont eu des débuts
difficiles mais il pouvait aller se
réfugier sous le toit parental en 1956
vous faites la première partie d'edith
piaf à l'olympia bah tout voilà tout est
arrivé ça a été le bout d'un premier
tunnel y en a eu d'autres tunnels pour
la suite mais celui-là venir vous gardez
de la chanteuse de cette rencontre
j'étais ébloui non pas par lé par la
féminité de la personne mais parce la
possession de ceux de ce total de ce
talent de c'était en même temps c'était
la mère des sept douleurs son amant
tenté mais certains venaient de se
fracasser sur 1
pic des açores et c'était le drame
incarner l qu est cette voix cette voix
mais dans la gestuelle qui était très
sobre j'ai regardé ça tous les soirs de
la coulisse tous les soirs la main au
même endroit sur la jupe noire tout le
temps la tête c'était très étudiée et
c'était elle mois après je suis devenu
quelqu'un de très remuant elle c'était
la sobriété mais chacun avec son voile à
sa mince je me suis dit voilà il faut
essayer de faire des choses assez
structuré pour pour pour permettre dans
leur canevas d'improviser après les
choses ont assez vite votre carrière est
lancée ces succès le triomphe même et
puis dans les années 75 80 c'est ce que
vous appelez votre fameuse traversée du
désert oui ça a été douloureux un
qu'intérieure et douloureux parce qu'un
désert vous pouvez traverser comme ça si
bon pouvait arriver à survivre mais un
désert où derrière chaque dune ya un
rebelle et où il ya des scorpions dans
les chaussures
et si le désert est mal fréquenté en
plus alors c'est louis ça a été
difficile il ya une anecdote que vous
racontez un souvent qu'une fois vous
allez dans un restaurant que vous
fréquentiez au moment où vous étiez
vraiment célèbre et là le restaurateur
avec nas femme mère m'a plus vu sur les
6 1 mais j'ai continué à travailler je
n'ai jamais cessé
y compris d'ailleurs guy carlier dit les
gens les artistes convoi puis dit tout
ce qu'ils chantent au japon bat c'est
vrai pour adamo c'est vrai que
quelques-uns de cas est allé japon il ya
les alliances françaises des tirailleurs
france profonde
mais on ne voyait plus sur les médias et
donc j'en avais ma femme j'ai dit tiens
je vais te présenter un petit resto où
on allait avec des musiciens autrefois
et le patron sidéré il me regardait
marcel amon ginette vient voir seulement
il n'a pas dit bonjour encore il se
tourne vers moi on fait péter jeu
croisé morts merci à l'amour on va tout
de suite vous entendre chanter parce
qu'on a très envie ch
je voulais donc d'installer sa se
reprennent d'autres sa fine de ses
anciennes chansons qui dure quatre ou
cinq minutes on n'a pas le temps non et
j'ai heureusement mais voilà on va être
très heureux à les installer
accompagné de votre guitariste keith à
brice ragots à brissago vous allez
affronter les bleus et d'azur c'est une
de ses chansons très ancienne qui a été
étouffé par bleu-blanc blu ray sur le
même discours je suis en train de
prendre perdre mon micro regarder et pas
qu tellement romain les i tellement
remuant que je fais tomber les micros on
entend quand même les gars oui oui très
vite les blés d'azir le tec le chef de
plateau me fais comme ça dans super on
vous écoute mercier gien alors ça
s'appelle dans les bleus et d'azur
les bleuets d'azur dans les grands blé
mûr nous font des clins d'oeil au bord
du clocher l'api vient chercher sa robe
le vent du mois d'août le coeur si doux
qu'on en boirait bien haut et l'herbe
d'amour se fait de velours au creux de
terrain attention mon gars c'est pas
tous les jours qu'on fait de la boue
avec ces trucs là attention mon gars
vétois des yeux bleus autant que tu veux
mais gamberge pas dans tes cheveux bruns
on plonge main
je vois le soleil c'est l'instant perdu
toujours attendu mais jamais pareil
et tandis qu'au scié
le silence c'est elle
quand on entend crier
quand t'es vieux qui bat
la vie ici bas qui j'en suis noyé
attention mon gars c'est pas tous les
jours qu'on fait de l'amour avec ces
trucs
attention manga vétois des yeux bleus
autant que tu veux mais n'en bouge pas
pour voir si c'est la tendance jusqu'à
dimanche prochain le dur dans les grands
bleus nous attendrons mieux vendu mois
d'où sera bien plus doux deuxième fois
et l'herbe d'amour
ce rôle a toujours
quand on reviendra ben tu vois mon gars
j'avais bien raison de faire attention
du gamberge des jeux qu'il peut dire mon
gars
si l'on reviendra
si beaucoup marré l'amant et abriterait
de mercy venez-vous réinstaller vous
auprès des auprès de moi je rappelle que
vous serez donc sur la scène de la
grande comédie à paris à partir de jeudi
prochain jusqu'au 31 octobre
merci beaucoup d'être venu nous voir
dans quelques minutes vous pourrez
retrouver les questions supplémentaires
que vous avez posé notre invité sur
notre site internet france 2 point fr
pourrait aussi poser d'autres questions
à notre invité de demain nous recevrons
le photographe reza
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi dans un instant la météo
de tania young à 20h vous avez rendez
vous avec david pujadas à 22h15
n'oubliez pas un oeil sur la planète
excellente après-midi